we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here is a trumpist caller
who is furious and is warning me my
Judgment Day is coming
I seriously hope that people get to sue
you for calling them mentally ill well
that's their prerogative
74 million people are mentally ill no
remember I didn't say 74 million people
are mentally ill
we have talked with cult experts and
mental health experts there are some
trumpists
who are just selfish people but they are
what we would call Sane they saw Trump's
policies as being good for them
personally financially that's one group
there's another group of people who are
simply brainwashed those are more like
the cult people they're not mentally ill
in the sense we normally mean they're
just brainwashed
there's another group that's just
ignorant they've fallen for lies that
they don't know are lies and then yes
there's a group that's mentally ill
we've interviewed some of them at the
rallies but I've never said 74 million
people who voted for Trump or mentally
ill criticize me for things I've said
please is that what it is pal
you know what when you stand before your
maker at the end on Judgment Day yeah
you're going to be one sorry dude I
understand me boy the election was
stolen cheating fraud you name it human
rights demon rack
I guess he stays on the phone for a
while I don't know if you can hear the
static
sounds like a car drove by
foreign
well listen when I stand before and face
Judgment at the end maybe I will be
sorry we'll have to wait and see if that
happens but uh the election was not
stolen Donald Trump genuinely lost
that's it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today Republicans with unlimited sick
days are voting against time off for
rail workers we'll tell you what's going
on
parents have refused the use of
vaccinated blood the blood from a
vaccinated person for a life-saving
surgery for their baby
oh boy and an Iranian man was shot dead
for celebrating that Iran lost a World
Cup game to the United States all of
those stories and many more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money there
on themselves as bad sign up at
joinpakman.com we will see you then